task sa chambre est emménagée sa
marraine est prête il ne manque plus
qu'elle
space celle que passa cesfa
est une afghane qui milite pour le droit
des femmes elle est issue d'une minorité
culturelle et religieuse
[Musique]
et forte dit-elle
depuis que les talibans ont repris le
pouvoir en Afghanistan en août 2021
farjana se cache dans un pays qu'on ne
peut nommer pour des raisons de sécurité
retournez chez elle et hors de question
pour le droit des femmes il me tuerait
aussi croient-elle son espoir trouver
refuge au Canada mais le processus
d'application est un parcours du
combattant
ne se bat pas seuls
[Musique]
Ottawa se sont donnés pour mission de la
faire venir au Canada
[Musique]
c'est très important pour moi et pour
tout nous que elle arrive ici au Canada
elle peut continuer son travail comme
militante des droits des femmes à ce
jour chacune de leurs tentatives c'est
soldées par un échec
a commencé par la possibilité
d'appliquer au programme humanitaire
pour les ressortissants afghan installés
à l'extérieur de l'Afghanistan phares
Anna répondait à tous les critères à
l'exception d'un seul elle ne peut pas
obtenir une référence de l'agence des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés
l'organisation n'a pas de bureau dans le
pays où elle se cache wide
pourquoi exiger d'un réfugié qui demande
l'asile de trouver quelqu'un qui pourra
confirmer qu'il est réfugié le Canada
peut effectuer ses vérifications
temporaire pour motif de protection lui
refuser puisque les fonctionnaires y ont
vu une demande de visa de visiteurs
j'ai trouvé ça difficile j'étais
vraiment déçue spécialement venant du
Canada j'avais honte comme un Canadien
que notre gouvernement peut traiter une
femme comme phare j'en ai comme ça c'est
sans parler du cas spécifique de faire
Zana le ministre de l'Immigration
chante-frayeux répond que les demandeurs
doivent suivre le processus mis en place
pour identifier les personnes
vulnérables
le système n'est pas fait pour que je
trie sur le volet les cas individuelles
portées à mon attention Chris à
l'extender a été ambassadeur du Canada
en Afghanistan et ministre de
l'Immigration selon lui le gouvernement
ne fait pas honneur à sa réputation de
défenseur des réfugiés et des femmes il
manque de volonté politique on peut agir
pour sur des questions de principe pour
protéger ceux et celles qui défendent
des droits de la personne les droits des
femmes en Afghanistan on devrait le
faire
sur les 40 000 afgangs vulnérables que
le Canada a promis d'accueillir près de
23000 d'entre eux ont foulé le seul
Canadien depuis août 2021
il y a des avions remplis du crayon qui
arrive au Canada et c'est tant mieux
leur situation est horrible mais si on
laisse pas de semaine nous pouvons faire
venir des avions plein d'ukrainien ou
pays nous pouvons faire la même chose
pour les Afghans pour faire Anna
l'espoir réside maintenant dans un
nouveau programme de parrainage de
réfugiés afghan lancé à la mi-octobre
[Musique]
le temps file son visa dans le pays où
elle se cache expire en janvier elle
court le risque d'être déporté en
Afghanistan
nous n'avons pas 5 6 ou 8 mois devant
nous dit-il faire Anna n'a que deux mois
nous devons mettre le paquet pour
s'assurer que le gouvernement ouvre son
dossier qu'il étudie la prouve et la
face venir ici
sa chambre latin
[Musique]